افادت وسائل الاعلام غربيه ان حكومه
الولايات المتحده يمكن ان تطرح تحقيقا
بخصوص استحواذ الى الماسك على منصه تويتر
فوفقا لتقرير صادر عن بلومبيرج تدرس
الحكومه الامريكيه ما اذا كان شراء ماسك
في الاستثمار او شركاء في الاستثمار
الاجنبي لديهم امكانيه الوصول الى بيانات
المستخدمين الخاصه على المنصه وقالت مصادر
قريبه من الموقف لوكاله بلومبرج ان
الحكومه تطلب مزيدا من التفاصيل حول
اتفاقيات ماسك الخاصه مع المستثمرين
الدوليين الذين لديهم حصص في الشركه جاء
هذا في وقت طلب فيها اعضاء مجلس الشيوخ
التحقيق في صفقه استحواذ ماسك على منصه
تويتر حيث قالوا بان ماسك انتهك قوانين
حمايه المستهلك واتخذ خطوات مثيره للقلاق
قواضات نزاهه وسلامه